[Música]
no meio do caminho tinha uma pedra tinha
uma pedra no meio do caminho
eu nunca esquecerei desse acontecimento
na vida das minhas retinas tão fatigadas
nunca esquecerei que no meio do caminho
tinha uma pedra tinha uma pedra no meio
do caminho
esse poema de drummond ilustra o tema da
nossa conversa hoje arquitetura hostil
em 2010 eu fui o continente africano
pela primeira vez e entre as muitas
coisas que aprendi com as viagens estão
a comida a bebida à cultura e à
arquitetura
você pode estar se perguntando por que
uma antropologia vim aqui falar de
arquitetura deixem de contar uma
história tendo nascido no bairro da
liberdade bairro que já foi considerado
o mais negro da cidade de salvador
nessa que é considerada a mais negra
fora do continente africano
foi ali na rua da feira no japão onde eu
nasci entre flores frutas pretos e
pardos que aprendido os conceitos
fundamentais para essa conversa a idéia
de pobreza e de arquitetura hostil
essa experiência compartilhada por nós
que ali moravam nos fez com que desde
muito cedo eu passasse a interrogar o
conceito de justiça social e espacial e
por que uma parte dessa cidade celebrada
nos cartões postais não era para todos
uma grande parcela dessa cidade que vira
as costas para a miséria para a pobreza
para a violência como espécie de
cegueira coletiva hoje indignação
seletiva que faz com que você se hit
porque tropeçou um cidadão dormindo na
rua atrapalhando o seu tráfego como uma
pedra no caminho
você certamente conhece essas imagens
são imagens do apartheid na áfrica do
sul ou imagens do campo de concentração
em auschwitz
a pergunta é por que algumas dessas
imagens
ainda nos incomodam nos causam dor e
desconforto
enquanto a idéia de moradores de rua
sendo açoitados por jato de água parece
tolerável
parece mesmo aceitável é disso que trata
a arquitetura hostil um conceito ainda
pouco conhecido embora por muitos de nós
já experimentado
nós vamos mostrar como a combinação de
um design agressivo com arquitetura
hostil tem produzido um mecanismo de
apartheid tão eficiente que nós
naturalizamos e mesmo aceitamos as
pessoas que vivem nas ruas da nossa
cidade elas são tratadas como coisa como
objeto como um lixo que precisa ser
removido e ser descartado
prefeitos de grandes capitais
gestores de condomínios e de corporações
têm utilizado largamente esse mobiliário
urbano agressivo como uma forma de
controle e ordenamento do espaço uma
espécie de justiça espacial às avessas
determinando quem pode e quem não pode
circular nas ruas das nossas cidades
esse paisagismo espinhoso esses bancos
antimendigos camas de prego cercas de
arame
elas não são uma casa do design elas são
uma estratégia pensada e projetada para
impedir que as pessoas circulem nas ruas
da cidade para tornar o contato entre as
pessoas algo impossível quase evitável
nós enxergamos muros e barreiras para
impedir que os ricos tropecem nos pobres
uma das cenas mais bonitas que eu vivi
na minha vida aconteceu na guiné bissau
país e segundo dados do banco mundial
tem mais de 80 por cento da sua
população vivendo abaixo da linha da
pobreza em países em que não há
distribuição de energia elétrica nem
distribuição de água e um pequeno
sistema hoteleiro depende basicamente de
geradores
foi ali no espaço improvisado para comer
em que os pratos já havia uma mesa com
múltiplos talheres para serem
compartilhados que eu me fiz a seguinte
pergunta quando nós deixamos
nos indignar quando a miséria e
sofrimento à fome
a perda do direito à cidade se tornou
algo naturalizava tendo saído lá no
bairro da liberdade
eu podia olhar os meus pés nos treinos e
anos no atlântico no índico e no
pacífico e foi lá do outro lado do
atlântico que eu pude conhecer coisas
que eu só via nos livros de história
eu vi de perto a arquitetura da
escravidão cidades e portos de onde
milhares de nossos ancestrais partiram
para uma vida de luta de fugas e de
insurreições foi lá também do outro lado
do atlântico que entendi que era
necessário uma outra cartografia para a
nossa cidade uma cartografia afetiva que
respeite as nossas histórias as nossas
trajetórias e as nossas memórias uma
geografia de afetos uma poética do
território que produza laços de
solidariedade que induza e fecunde nova
tecnologia de pertencimento
precisamos de cidade com redução da
pobreza e da desigualdade social e
econômica mas também espacial
precisamos desenvolver soluções poéticas
e políticas que acolha as pessoas em
lugar de silenciar projetos e histórias
de vida foi lá do outro lado do
atlântico que nós entendemos que é onde
se construiu a maior quitte tura da
violência e da escravidão se nós
conseguimos sobreviver aos traumas do
exílio forçado da escravidão que porque
construímos juntos pessoas de diferentes
etnias diferentes origens diferentes
línguas estratégias coletivas de
resistência
nós sabemos que os lugares carregam
histórias
as cidades também quantas histórias
quantas memórias quantos projetos de
vida
deixado morrer muito obrigado
[Música]